When do you want to die?
King of death is busy, but
He can make you a place now
Is it early, later possible, you in the future will book the date
Old with life I lived it fully.
Maybe a little bored and ready for your appointment
Now maybe you're thinking about it
But when the appointed time comes to you the king of death
The date is not in the future
Because you do not live in the future
You always live in the present
Therefore, you always die in the present
For the king of death will come to all sooner or later
Humans formed a foolish relationship with death.
Such as the hostage whom she loved.
Humans say to themselves
The few decades they have taken from the King of Death are the right amount.
Living long and healthy will be boring
Their lives will be abnormal.
Imagine all the problems if the king of death took leave.
He will whisper to you the king of death it
A friend of yours
Near always, human beings grow; Bigger, stronger, healthier and smarter.
At first, then comes the harvest of the slow death king
"Death is part of life." He whispers.
Death gives life meaning
This is madness. Suffering does not give happiness.
Happiness means itself.
If you torture people to make them appreciate life.
You will be a monster.
Just like this person
There is no father asking the king of death to whiten the skin of his son.
Weaken their bones, darken their eyes and minds and make them paralyzed
In a thousand ways over several decades and eventually kill them
To give life meaning.
But what will you do? The world contains pain and death.
That is why your mind will believe lies that horrible things you can not keep away from
Is a good thing for you.
Although death is part of life
Cholera was part of life until humans
They developed wells and sanitary drains to separate water from waste
Myopia was part of life until it disappeared.
Just because something is part of nature does not make it good or necessary
It is nature to live life dirty,
Strong and short.
It is normal for humans to look at what
Nature has a starting point.
As a task paper, when people concentrate
Technology evolves
With that capacity, we can make life better
And now some simple tools with a real promise to slow down or stop the vulnerability
Something has become clear on the horizon.
Which makes it questionable
What is the power of the king of death?
With little time and focus, can humans make it
These simple instruments of shields and swords make the king of death in his place
Maybe for ever? Maybe but
And if the first generation of the two
Maybe they live today
Generation lives a healthy life
The length of time they wish
But to make this happen, we must eradicate the minds of thousands of years
Who accept death
Death is not the solution to imagined and volatile problems
Face the challenges that a longer life will bring
Humans will not long for the king of death
They create a new king of death to solve their problems. Just when our cities grew up
We did not mix water to retrieve cholera
Human beings must ignore the acquired deficit
Who was imposed upon them by the king of death and their minds
And do not look at weakness and disease as a natural and inevitable
But as a disease of the past and must be attacked as all diseases
As a disease of the past
Which affects all human beings
As a source of unhappiness
There is no suffering in your near future
But in your presence
The question is when will we start a concentration project
Our attention and our equipment are against
The King of Death is an important thing
And teams only one day
May be inevitable
In any aspect of the future crack you will find yourself on them
She travels for ever
Or fall back into the abyss
Have you been late?
We probably will not win the war against death.
For death has all the power
But perhaps we can win the battle against the thing after death, the same age.
There is a real chance that you will live longer and have a healthy life
But do you have to do this? We'll find out in this video